[Music]
[Applause]
also NBC Sports is going to broadcast
the Nascar Cup Series inaugural street
race in Chicago this weekend as the
sport celebrates its 75th anniversary
and Dale Earnhardt Jr is going to be
part of that good to see you Junior how
did this race come about downtown
Chicago
well we used to race at Chicagoland out
in Juliet which is about I don't know 45
minutes an hour away
uh it's a great market for us and NASCAR
wanted to get back to the Chicago Market
I think that um
the way this began to be honest with you
was through the um High racing software
which is a PC video game
uh simulation whatever you want to call
it but it's a it's the most realistic
racing game on the market today and they
were able with that product
NASCAR was able to say hey
use uh you know use the Chicago Streets
and build us a street course and then
put your customers on there to drive it
and race it and give it feedback
and so that's kind of how this all
started years ago before you had a PC
simulation uh or any kind of a video
game you basically had to you know build
the racetrack and hope it worked right
uh now with all the technology we have
Dan uh to be able to build a race track
and simulation and have drivers real
world drivers and great simulator
drivers
uh drive on the track and
and fix all the nuances and all the
problems that are going to occur it
saves NASCAR it saves track promoters
Builders millions and millions of
dollars and it probably saved uh the
same you know just an incredible amount
of money in in sort of understanding how
to put this event on so that's how it
got started they
actually ran a simulated race on the
streets of Chicago on on this track in
the simulated World they put it live on
TV it was called the pro Invitational
actually was part of that uh and it was
all of our real world drivers so this
has been a this has been in the works
for about three years okay how would I
do if let's say I got into this
simulator
you'd be you'd be terrible
um you know I think everybody that gets
in a simulator the one thing that's
missing is obviously the seat of the
pants feel of driving a real car and the
grip and the tires and everything being
connected to the road that we all know
so well when we drive down the highway
um so it takes a while to you it's
basically you're you know learning how
to drive a race car missing one critical
uh sensor right and
once you figure out how to work through
that you get really good at it but I
could teach you if you really wanted to
get into it but uh it's a lot of fun
it's as close as you can get to driving
a real world race car without having you
know leaving the comfort of your house
and spending you know thousands and
millions of dollars to compete well I'm
also wondering about the future of
NASCAR if if you're looking at Formula
One and the success that formula one has
had and they're you know in the streets
of Monte Carlo like how important is
NASCAR changing some of these venues to
get it into downtown Chicago or you know
some of these other cities or you know
to do something that maybe you're going
to take from Formula One
I think that racing in the streets of
some of the bigger cities in the in the
country is a new chapter for NASCAR I
expect it to be highly successful it's
going yes you're limited on where you
can go what you know what cities and and
what areas could embrace it and where it
could actually put you know function
properly
there's also great examples of that
obviously in F1 but also in IndyCar
um in uh the Canadian NASCAR series runs
uh Run Street courses as well so we
there's lots of places for NASCAR to
look for for examples and success and
Leadership on how to pull this off
we have you know when we we race out in
Juliet because you know we we can't
build an oval right next to the city we
can't build that oval race track that we
want to race at in these big markets
right in our residential areas so our
racetracks for example Atlanta is in
Hampton you know it's not even near
Atlanta it's 30 45 minutes outside of
Atlanta all of our big tracks are
connected to these um you know these
dense populated areas in this in this in
the country but they're they're they're
20 to 20 minutes to an hour drive
outside the city to get to them uh this
is a great opportunity to really put the
product right in the middle of the city
right in the Heart of the City there's
going to be an incredible uh amount of
uh you know views with the skyline uh
it's going to be a beautiful uh
experience visually
uh for for not only people here in
attendance like myself but for people
watching at home uh we're gonna see
shots and imagery that we've never
experienced in now NASCAR at least at
the top cup level and so I'm looking
forward to that I just walked out of the
hotel this morning walked across walked
down the racetrack on the way to the TV
compound it feels surreal to be walking
these streets that I was I was here a
month ago before the track was even
built or there was a barrier up or any
kind of you know resemble anything that
would you know that would break you know
you would recognize at a racetrack and
it's so surreal to be walking down these
streets now
lined with walls and barriers and as
they prepare for this race it's um
it's an incredible moment for NASCAR it
really is and I believe that it's going
to be a big success and I'm glad I'm
here for it how would you do how would
you do if you had to race this weekend I
probably wouldn't do that great it's um
you know I would I say this often but
it's the only way I can really
articulate it
racing at the Xfinity truck level or the
Nascar cup level these guys do it every
single week they live it every day
they're in the simulator every day
preparing all week long they're in
meetings every day for somebody even
like me with all you know with two
decades of experience to not have raced
in a year
or more to hop in one of these cars you
would get you would get
um you would you would be humbled
quickly because they're in that cycle
week after week after week they're doing
it over and over and over and they know
they know how to get that car all the
way to the limit of the grip of the tire
right up to that moment where that tire
is about to break traction for me to hop
in there after not being in the car for
a year to find that limit is really
really hard and you and I would I would
rarely get up to that limit I would be
you know quite a ways off of it so
you know it I I uh I'm gonna compete a
couple times this year in Xfinity series
we're racing at Bristol and uh we got a
couple you know we got a couple events
we're gonna run but
um I don't know I don't I don't go in
with high expectations but I'll tell you
that because it's pretty humbling to
compete with those guys when they're
doing it every single week if you ever
have a moment of race where you didn't
want to get in the car
um
probably
yeah on my mind a couple days ago but
Rockingham after my dad passed away that
was the next race we went to
I didn't want to race I didn't want to
be there but uh I knew I mean I didn't
want to be anywhere else you know it was
kind of one of them situations where you
didn't want to be anywhere and you
didn't want to be doing nothing but you
needed to be doing something and it was
just a weird place to be emotionally and
mentally but
um
there are times when you know you might
be sick or feeling bad
um or you know the car wasn't fast in
practice and you're worried about how
having a frustrating day but I never
walked up to the race car and didn't
want to climb in it didn't want to do
what I was getting ready to do I've
always felt lucky privileged um
I felt you know like I you know I I was
right where I was supposed to be
great to talk to you I can hear the
excitement in your voice about this
event and uh hope you have fun this
weekend
I appreciate man it's good to see you uh
I hope you're doing well and thanks for
having me on how are the girls doing
oh man I just was with them all week
we're having a great time they're doing
great Nicole's too Alice five life
couldn't be any better any more on the
way
no sir
is good for me I'm uh I feel blessed
so the the the the pits are closed is
that what you're saying I would I would
say so yeah that's that's the that's we
got a full house man it's wide open good
good to see you thank you thank you
Junior that's uh Dale Earnhardt Jr NBC
Sports NASCAR analyst and uh the streets
of Chicago Sunday evening 5 30 Eastern
on NBC in peacock pre-race coverage
starting at five eastern